la ferme intention cette demande
jean michel mr contre eux catherine
laborde d'accord this is hernych
ok mais là ici ici attention alors c'est
le pôle est là elle est comme l'art de
finale attention on y va on démarre par
jean michel maire mais quel mytho 58 58
km fonctionnaires 100 km en maille s'il
vous plaît bien suit pas et ça me semble
un peu triste affaire n'est pas
complètement la zone de confort aux
allées à bout
posté par catherine laborde chez vous on
doit aller très vite a pour regarder ça
vient on y voit là mon chéri tunisien
parce que chez nous on va pas s'en
sortir donc tout à fait 40 à l'essai sur
meriem a des qualités mais ont merdé pas
merci madame tomber mais à la baisse à
la 62e allez-y 62 contrat ni mallet 49
c'est pas mal du tout géré à dilma des
qualifiés c'est le record absolu
c'est le record il en a d'autres merde
fort merci nous attentions les chéris du
filet mais c'est la demi-finale à 3 à 3
le meilleur me rencontrera il s'arrache
vais tout faire pour que tu gagnes ma
chérie on y va matthieu delormeau c'est
parti
pour recel de vol deux très beaux scores
de mathieu de la terrible et très beau
score de mathieu d'orgue la finale se
joue en deux points
égalité si géraldine fait plus aller
directement à 10 chefs et moi on fera
pour vous départager 52 s'est perdue
produire a dit merci
[Rires]
voilà tandis qu'un 75 je sais vous une
de leurs mots 61 10 en plus il avait
mordu à c
ouais bah journée de visite et comme on
dit attention c'est parti je vais faire
comme ça peu marre de ces mordus c'est
mort ces mordus et mais qu'est-ce qu'on
peut avoir un arbitrage harmonieux
ces moments du sport et retrouver la
chaîne soit tu as pensé quoi est mort
ouais je suis morte assure la gueule il
doit pas mordre
dépanordi 64 c'est pas mordu à points
0,37 watts a merdé là c'est vrai c'est
impossible alors matelas la misère et la
mâche pas ses mots et ses pertes
initiales et je sais c'est non c'est au
cri miser entre les lignes bis bien
entre les lignes c'est gagner merci
mathieu nault
sarah tuera pas avec ton cadeau ma
beauté
merci à tous
[Musique]